a while back uh somebody made a face
fake
of me and put it onto the
internet and social media
and so I am in it you know it's well
it's my face put over uh Kai The
Hitchhiker
smash smash
he's the famous smash smash Master you
know he's that handyman that [__]
couldn't find a nail because you know
who that is
that's him baby he's that hitchhiking
nail Hunter boy you know he's that
DeWalt anyway there's a documentary
about him he's the famous hitchhiker
that hit a guy with a uh Hatchet and
hatcheted a guy out
to save a um
this kind of thicker Little Biscuit lady
who was getting her you know getting
attacked or hugged out it's the whole
story is insane
but anyway what happened was so somebody
put my face onto a Kai The Hitchhiker
onto his story right it went around on
social medias we put it up on social
media
um so he filed a lawsuit he says or this
document says uh Kayla Bell mcgilvery a
jailhouse lawyer he is apparently
according to this he's a lawyer now
um
says I've just filed a lawsuit uh
uh because of your the video you made
um
if you want to settle outside of Court
the U.S Marshals will be coming to your
door
uh to hand you a summons
you'll never
um if you want to settle outside of
Court now's your chance
I'll settle for what my costs are
which is approximately
so and so amount
um
and then he wants the videos down uh
uh so
and he will withdraw the lawsuit
and we can go our separate ways
um I don't know
uh
uh I'm a jailhouse lawyer and he has
nine years of litigation experience and
he may look this is
I don't know how to handle this uh but
that's why I mean I literally
was just seeing the documentary about
him
and here is this and it's funny because
during the documentary I
I think you can relate some with this
fearile child this young man who
something was uncomfortable or wrong in
his upbringing
you know something was off
um and he appears very like kind of
manic a lot and you know also there's a
lot of transient people that's some of
the energy that's out there uh
uh but a good-hearted dude you know
kind of dude that would just you know
give you this skirt off his back you
know or whatever
and
that's good and I you know you kind of
love the guy
you know uh but just an amazing
interesting story and then got this this
court summons and this all appears very
real so I'm gonna have to talk with a
talk with an attorney I got a buddy over
there at Morgan and Morgan
I'll hit him up and see maybe on the
next solo episode we can actually
address that and I can get some more
information
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one